l'espoir de retrouver vivants les
passagers de l'avion disparu au large de
l'indonésie et de plus en plus minces
des plongeurs ont retrouvé des parties
de l'épave d'un boeing 737 500 à une
profondeur de 23 mètres en mer de java
nous avons reçu des rapports de l'équipe
de plongeurs indiquant que la visibilité
dans l'eau est bonne est claire ce qui a
permis de découvrir certaines parties de
l'avion
nous sommes sûrs que c'est le point où
l'avion s'est écrasé quelques heures
auparavant des morceaux de corps de
vêtements et de métal ont été remontés à
la surface par des sauveteurs
le sonar d'un navire de la marine a
également détecté un signal de l'avion à
l'endroit précis du dernier contact
établi par les pilotes avant la
disparition de l'avion
des pêcheurs d'un archipel au nord de la
côte de jakarta ont déclaré avoir
entendu une explosion vers 14h30 heure
locale heure à laquelle le ministère du
transport confirme la perte de contact
avec l'avion
les secouristes à jakarta ont déclaré
avoir reçu des informations de certains
pêcheurs qui disent avoir entendu un
bruit d'explosion
mais pour le moment nous ne pouvons pas
confirmer si l'explosion provenaient de
l'avion ou non nous avons trouvé des
débris et nous soupçonnons qu'ils
proviennent de l'avion
cependant nous devons encore confirmer
si elles font vraiment partie de l'avion
de la compagnie sri figea you were
samedi dix navires de guerre ont été
déployés pour la recherche des victimes
et participer à d'éventuels sauvetages
dans la tente les proches des passagers
se sont rendus à l'aéroport
une fois que j'ai entendu les
informations sur l'accident j'ai demandé
à certains de mes amis puis je suis venu
à l'aéroport pour vérifier dés
informations
et là j'ai découvert que c'était vrai
que quatre de mes proches étaient parmi
les passagers de l'avion disparu
le président joe cole we do do a adressé
ses condoléances au nom de tous les
indonésiens
au nom du gouvernement et du peuple
indonésien
j'exprime mes sincères condoléances à la
suite de cette catastrophe
j'ai ordonné au ministre des transports
à l' agence nationale de recherche et de
sauvetage
avec l'aide des militaires et de la
police de mener une opération de
recherche et de sauvetage aussi
rapidement que possible pour les
victimes
les présidents russe vladimir poutine
lui a emboîté le pas en adressant ses
sincères condoléances
une catastrophe qui rappelle l'accident
d'octobre 2010 8 ou 189 personnes
avaient trouvé la mort dans le crash
d'un boeing 737 max en mer de java
accident qui avait mis en cause la
société américaine boeing et son nouveau
modèle mais l'appareil incriminé ici
serait un boeing 737 classic
le président indonésien a réclamé une
enquête pour déterminer les causes
exactes de l'accident